y tras la tormenta la aparente calma
este domingo en el marco del 60
aniversario de la firma del tratado del
Eliseo que simboliza la cooperación
franco-almana se reencontraron Emanuel
macron y olafels quienes en los últimos
tiempos han dado señales de
distanciamiento por falta de
comunicación y decisiones que no han
sentado bien a uno y otro socio pese a
las fracturas por el precio de la
energía o las prioridades en materia de
defensa ambos líderes se mostraron
dispuestos a avanzar de la mano en un
momento complicado para el viejo
continente afectado por la guerra la
crisis energética y una inflación
disparada
Alemania y Francia porque han despejado
el camino de la reconciliación tienen
que convertirse en Pioneros en la
reconstrucción de nuestra Europa juntos
Pioneros en primer lugar de la
construcción conjunta de un nuevo modelo
energético Más allá de nuestras
diferencias
el motor Franco alemán es una máquina de
compromiso una máquina bien engrasada
pero que a veces puede ser ruidosa y dar
testimonio de un arduo trabajo funciona
con halagos y simbolismos vacíos
también aprovecharon su reunión para
transmitir un mensaje de unidad liderado
por las dos principales economías de la
Unión Europea hacia el pueblo ucraniano
dejando atrás las últimas disensiones
por el envío de tanques pesados Que de
momento Berlín rechaza
después del 24 de febrero nuestro
continente no se dejó dividir ni eludió
sus responsabilidades y nuestro apoyo
inquebrantable al pueblo ucraniano
continuará en todas las áreas
continuaremos apoyando a Ucrania durante
el tiempo y la amplitud que sea
necesario juntos como europeos en
defensa de nuestro proyecto de paz
europeo
seis décadas después de la firma de la
paz entre ambas naciones Alemania y
Francia esperan ahora dejar de lado los
problemas para conjugar la que han
denominado refundación de Europa